[Music]
kara in h town houston texas what's up
cara
hi thanks for taking my call guys thank
you for calling what's up
well i feel like my family's in a
position that maybe some other americans
are in uh my husband is a nurse
and um
we i was really hoping that his
exemption
for the vaccine would be approved and we
just found out last night that it was
denied
and kind of the cms um
my key mandate is is everywhere and so
at the end of the month you know his
income will be no more and our health at
this point and i'm just thinking are we
looking at a career change do you guys
have any advice i mean we
are debt-free but our health we have an
emergency fund um we've got three kids
who aren't even school age yet so like
there's a lot of emotion and thoughts
that are going on through our house
right now so we've got a lot to think
about yeah so number one you're right i
know lots of people are going through
all sorts of job transitions and are
staring
this in the face and so
um thanks for being brave and calling
and putting it out there for us to walk
through um so here's how i
make these decisions this is just the
matrix that i use right wrong or
indifferent and i just want to there is
no way to talk about
covet and vaccine mandates and job loss
without people losing their minds so
that's fine
here's how i make these type of
decisions
i always want to back out of these
things and take the
air or the emotion and set it to the
side for a second those feelings are
real the emotion is real
but what are the facts in front of me
the facts are this
i have a principle or a value it could
be about mandates it could be about
being asked to steal at work it could be
it could be about anything
i have a set of core principles and my
employer is violating those principles
so much so that i am opting to have no
job
that's my that's my stance that's my
platform that's my that's that's where
i'm sitting
and come what may
i will have to
work 50 part-time jobs i'm gonna have to
go to another hospital i'm gonna have to
move i'm gonna have to do other things
but my values are that important
and almost always unless there's just
something way out
i've got high respect for anybody who
says i've got a set of values that i
simply i can't i can't move forward on
this
right
so i want to take the emotion aside and
look at the reality the reality is you
guys have 30 days or a little less than
30 days before you're going to have no
income
so let's take out the mandates let's
take out the frustration the anger
what are y'all gonna do for food and
rent
and
transportation
what are you gonna do
and that's when you i think career
change is it time to go i think you put
all that stuff after you take care of
your four walls right you're gonna be
able to keep your house you're gonna be
able to keep your little kids fed you're
gonna be able to keep the lights and
electricity running you're gonna be able
to get to and from the grocery store
that that becomes where my initial how
am i going to solve for this
so what's your plan there
well we have taken a look at the budget
um i i work
you know i make about twice as much as
my husband and and so we are we are
extremely extremely thankful great um
for that so when it comes to our four
roles you know maybe we're only taking
between we're kind of slimming
everything down and maybe we're only
taking between 500 and 1000 out every
month from our emergency fund and that
covers that that covers everything so
our four walls we're good nobody's going
to go hungry
um you know we can put gas in the car
our health you know
you know we'll be paid
um we just we had big goals yeah well
yeah and here's the thing not by your
hand but in your lap
you didn't cause it yeah but you had a
values based decision and somebody
dropped something in your lap and they
called your bluff and you said cool i'm
sticking by our values whatever they
happen to be
and yeah so
i
i don't want you to make a practice of
living off the emergency fund but here
we are and so i think now is you're
hustling that's not our intention that's
right that's right of course it's not
but now your husband's able to say
do i love nursing do i want to find a
place whether it's on a college campus
or at an elementary school or a travel
do i love this this is what i want to be
doing and i just got caught up in a in a
mess that will go away at some point or
will reduce at some point or may never
change that right
do i love nursing do i love helping
people do i want to go back to school
and get some different credentials i
think you're you're in a position and
it's a fortunate position to ask that
question
and then say what comes next and i'm
gonna hold my head up high anytime i
make decisions and i'm angry or i am
raged out i never make good choices
i'm out of this profession i quit this
is the work actually i love nursing i
hate that this thing is happening here
where can i find nursing where can i
find human care where can i find
connection other places and i'll get on
that road and maybe there's none maybe
there's not i don't know enough to i
haven't kept close enough
tabs on it there may not be any places
left to go and it may be that this is
i've got to go do something else but i
think you can enter a season of one
month two months and figure it out i'll
give you a copy hang on the line we'll
give you a copy of our friend ken
coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
and it's just got some good exercises to
walk through it and say what do i
actually want to be doing and what i
actually love
is your family united in this decision
my husband and i we are 100 on board i
can't say the same for you know some
extended family
kind of a mixed bag they don't get they
they don't get a vote for the last day
yeah they don't get involved my husband
and i we're we made this decision a long
time ago when you know we're like what
do we need to put on this exemption that
fits with our family and what we believe
and what we have already set forth is
how we believe and feel and all that
um you know natural immunity is like not
a thing in the cms world they don't
really care that we have that um but yes
we are fully united we're supportive
of you know that decision and whatever
it means for us in the coming days i
just feel like it's
i know my husband's an extremely hard
worker and he has never been in the
situation where
his job is
um
being taken from him you know from you
know and this is the decision that we
made just like if you were a poor
performer that's a decision you made
right well
it's there is something about
um
there's something about
knowing something's coming
and then it shows up
right and we are often caught off guard
by how much it hurts how scary it is we
knew it was coming we knew this was
coming down the road and then it's here
i hear this a lot when i used to sit
with folks who had long-term illnesses
we know that granddad's gonna pass away
and if you did but when he actually
passes away it's something else right
and people are caught off guard by that
so
don't be caught off guard by how off
guard you're gonna feel right
i want you and your husband to have a
regular practice if i were you i'd make
this a daily practice
three minutes
go i'm scared i'm kind of freaked out
i'm pissed off i'm angry about all this
or taking a job away that i love
and then you go and then you get your
three minutes and then all right what
are we gonna be about solving this today
i'm gonna make sure that we've got
purpose we've got a paycheck what do you
want to actually do with your life how
are you gonna get back on the horse and
let's go down that road i'm just not
gonna i'm not gonna let anger and
emotion and rage take me over because i
know i'm gonna make less
wise decisions when that happens yeah
and the only thing i'll add to that john
is he's got to be about the business of
getting to work clearly he's a hard
worker and he might have to swallow his
pride have some humility and go do jobs
that he would never otherwise do right
now but planning on using the emergency
fund like we talked about earlier is a
bad plan i want you to have use it
because you absolutely need it so if you
can avoid touching that that would be my
goal personally is to go well he can
work he can make an extra 500 to a
thousand bucks a month to help us avoid
dipping into the emergency fund while he
looks for something new while he figures
out what he really wants to do so that
would be my personal goal just adding on
top of that the financial part yeah
and again i want to i feel like i'm a
broken record sometimes
nobody well they're talking about um you
know talking about work we're talking
about relationship issues we're talking
about investing
nobody it's it's a neurological thing
nobody makes good decisions when they're
in fight or flight when they are
consciously stewing they are living in
this rage and they're angry
i get it's real i get it's visceral i
get it hurts
and then you gotta set that down and say
okay what do i gotta do right now focus
on the future next steps that's right
i'm gonna choose optimism in a mess i'm
gonna choose it because why not right
because why not